the free network foundation is a
nonprofit organization that helps
communities to build their own computer
networks your gateway access to the
internet for almost everyone is
controlled by just a few firms it
occurred to us that that really can have
an impact on not only whether people can
access but what kind of information is
available to people and with the way
that networks are currently set up I
think a lot of people's voices are not
going to transfer your so we thought
maybe there was something that we could
do to help communities regain control of
their own access to information wireless
mesh networks are one way that can help
people regain some control over how we
communicate with one another we're
trying to democratize people's access to
information I don't know exactly where
we're going right now we're building
networks we'll see what happens down the
road